hello everybody so for most people
who'll be watching this
tomorrow is Epiphany or in the Orthodox
tradition it is theophany so I wanted to
look a little bit at the symbolism of
that feast because we know a lot about
Christmas but epiphany or theophany is a
holiday that for most people has been
has fallen to the wayside but the
symbolism of that feast is quite
important to think about this is
Jonathan pecho welcome to the symbolic
world
and so at the beginning of Christianity
the two feasts the Feast of the Nativity
of Christ and the feast of Epiphany or
theophany were joined together and what
it was about really was a celebration of
what I would call an ontological
category was a celebration not of an
event per se but of a state of being
that is it was the celebration of the
manifestation of the logos in the world
the manifestation of God to the world
and so within the feast of Epiphany or
theophany I think I'm going to use the
word epiphany because most of my viewers
are used to that term so for most of the
so what they were celebrating at the
beginning of Christianity was the
manifestation of the logos and so within
the feast of Epiphany
there were several references to events
in Christ's story or in the Holy story
there was the Nativity of Christ of
course then there was also the visit of
the Magi we also had the baptism of
Christ and the miracles of Christ in
general but mostly the miracle of the
wedding feast of Cana and so what all
those things have in common are places
in Christ story where we he manifests
himself to the world where people see
that he's in the world and so the the at
some point the two feasts were separated
for most Christians a few Christians
still celebrate them together but for
most Christians at some point December
twenty-fifth became the Nativity feast
and then epiphany was celebrated on
January 6 and then what was celebrated
is there became separate in different
locales for exactly in the East we
celebrate mostly the baptism of Christ
and in the West they celebrate mostly
the visit of the Magi but what's
important is to notice the relationship
between those two things
that is the Magi coming to find the
Christ child is seen in the tradition as
these foreign peoples these three Magi
who become in the tradition three kings
and it's important that there are three
kings because their authority figures in
in different place different parts of
the world in the Western tradition the
Magi came from different locales in the
East there was an Ethiopian Magi one
from India and I don't remember or the
other one comes from but you had these
these kings kind of joining together and
then coming to to Bethlehem to recognize
the this child as being the new king or
the highest king or the manifestation of
the of the king in the world whereas in
the Eastern tradition it's actually
mostly the baptism icon because when
Christ came out of the water there was a
voice that came from heaven and said
this is my son today I have begotten
thee you know and or or do as as he says
and so the people around would have
heard a voice which man if which showed
the manifestation of the logos which
said this this thing this this specific
person is where to look at just as the
three kings coming to to see to find the
Christ child and then in the traditions
of the church that notion of the
manifestation of the logos will appear
in different traditions but first what's
important to say is that we can see it
at a cosmological level some Christians
are uncomfortable in interpreting it
that way but it's it can be helpful to
see it because we all know in the
tradition that the logos is associated
with light which makes absolute sense
because light is what reveals the world
to us and logos in terms of how it
unites multiplicities into into
identifiable things is is similar to
light it's it's analogous to light and
light can help us understand
what logos means and so in terms of the
cosmological symbolism we can imagine
the nativity feast Christmas as the
hidden light let's say as let's say the
beginning of the day at midnight when
the Sun is beginning to rise the
beginning of the of the the year at at
the Solstice where the lowest the
shortest day has happened and now the
day's are going to start to get longer
but it's still a secret because it's
still hidden we can't perceive it yet
and so the imagery of Christ being born
in a cave the imagery of Christ being
placed in a manger of these this hidden
dark you know low place and now is
slowly going to rise up and now the the
the end of the Christmas season in in
the traditional Western calendar was
epiphany when that light shines forth
and now we start to notice that the days
are getting longer that the Sun is
higher up in the sky than is going to
continue to to rise up and so in the in
the notion of the Magi recognizing
Christ or Christ coming out of the water
of baptism or also him revealing his
himself as the one who forms the world
at the with his miracles or at the the
feast of Cana all of that makes sense
all together and now in terms of the
traditions you can see how that follows
through with the traditions in in the
West that there's a lot of traditions
for example where I where I grew up in
Quebec the the traditions of epiphany
were that they would bake a cake a flat
cake a gallant we call it like a big
cookie and then hidden inside the cake
would be a seed or a pod or something
like a bean and so the cake would be cut
up and people would eat the the cake and
whoever would find the the seed would
then be the king for the day and so you
can see how this eating of the cake and
finding the seed is the manifestation of
the law
and then whoever is able to find the
logos in his food that is you know you
you the idea would be kind of like
taking Lobby probably did people didn't
swallow the see but you can see the
image of having the seed inside you of
swallowing that seed and having it
having it within you and finding you
know the most important thing finding
the logos in yourself and then becoming
the king for the day and then whoever in
the community whoever is able to find
the most important thing or is able to
find the identity or the the center of
something then immediately becomes the
center you know an image of the center
of that thing so the notion of him
becoming the king or her becoming the
queen for the day is a perfect image of
the manifestation of the logos and then
in the same way in the the more the more
Eastern traditions at theophany what we
do is we bless the waters okay and so
one of the one of the traditions you'll
see this in in Russia and in Eastern
countries in Greece and and in Orthodox
countries you know they'll stand on the
side of a water bank and they'll throw a
cross out in the water then people will
dive in and then they'll find the cross
and and lift it up and whoever you know
finds the cross winds and so it's the
same as finding the seed inside the cake
whoever finds the cross I mean obviously
they don't necessarily say that he
becomes the king for the day but there's
this idea of in the dark waters it
hidden in the darkness lifting up this
most important thing you know like I
talked about in in the video the
metaphysics of Peppe of finding the
golden ball in the water and then
bringing it up so that you become a
prince okay it's it's all the same
symbolism finding the seed in the cake
becoming a king for the day it's the
same thing as a frog going into the
water in the in the Greek or Russian
tradition finding the cross and bringing
it out you know to celebrate this this
arrival of light the the the dawn dawn
of a new day so all this symbolism cost
comes together another
aspect of the symbolism is also that at
during theophany season the priests will
go around and will bless houses and so
in that sense the blessing of the houses
and the blessings of the water is also
is this sense of the logos spreading out
into the entire world and also holding
the world together you know being the
source of life the source of light for
everything that you can imagine so going
out into people's houses and blessing
them bringing that spiritual influence
or the that the idea of a blessing is
this conferring or this finding of let's
say revealing the the connection of that
thing to the life of God to the life of
the church to the life of the community
it's connecting things together
that's usually what blessing means and
you mean all the symbolism of a baptism
then comes in of then Christ also like I
said coming out of the water to hear the
voice of God from the heavens saying you
know this is my son and so the blessing
of the waters is that is the how that
event of light coming out can then
participate and fill the entire world at
that time and so I hope this is useful
to kind of understand a little bit what
the symbolism of theophany and epiphany
was so before I end I just want to say
I've been trying something new for the
first time usually I write down my
interpretations because I isn't my first
language and I tend to stutter and
hesitate and so I'm going to try once in
a while to improvise the way I did now
and maybe in the comments tell me what
you think tell me if you find that I'm
clear enough that my ideas are focused
enough and that I am NOT stuttering too
much and saying hums in Oz all the time
and so I hope you enjoyed it and I'll
see you soon